insomma uno che sta succedendo
pagliaccio bene
oggi andremo ad un compleanno un
pagliaccio un po strano già invitato il
suo compleanno mi piace di compleanni
l'importate che si mangia ma non me ne
farò una trappola comunque sbrighiamoci
busta per parte
quello centrale che ci sono più persone
ei non riesce ad entrare
sono entrato
dai piedi t mi siedo qui
ok a fianco c'è
qualcuno con un'armatura un po strana
benvenuti nella sala giochi di paci si
chiama così il pagliaccio se già
invitato un campo strano c'è qualcosa di
strano in questo invito un caffè adesso
sembra tutto a posto quello mi piace mio
outfit ho anche cambiato capelli così
siamo arrivati alla sala giochi di farsi
bello così povero adesso beh io esplora
un po lise
benvenuti nella sala giochi di paci e tu
di ha detto ciao fatto questo posto
sembra fantastico ho detto io guardati
intorno mentre cerchi di trovare la
chiave della plancia di guardarsi
intorno mentre lei cerca la chiave che
finora sembra tutto tranquillo un gioco
con la globo sin che bene giochiamo
frigole vivo così evitiamo di giocare
finora è tutto tranquillo sembra un
invito normale ha detto non trovo la
chiave ok pensi che potresti aiutarmi a
trovarla ha chiaramente
e un'altra ragazza gli ha detto certo
vogliamo entrare divertirci
ok prima parola chiave controlliamo
vediamo se non basta trovare una moda ma
voi lasciate un mi piace e volete
scoprire che invito avete ricevuto
lasciate un mi piace l'ultima cifra nel
vostro mi piace corrisponde al maghetto
di un compleanno di uno di questi
personaggi
se volete scriveteci nei commenti che
personaggio mi è capitato erice vorreste
davvero un invito a di compleanno dopo
il personaggio ci andreste da ben
rifiutereste scrivete giorno dei
commenti io vedevo l'ora di leggere i
vostri commenti ci sia qualcosa qua dopo
stavamo portando in bagno viene trovato
la chiave prova abbiamo fatto a finire
l'altra ragazza dice possiamo andare a
giocare adesso certo
aspetto solo che apra la porta a cuocere
il bagno ok sì noi siamo andati in bagno
a cercare la chiave non c'è
italia di turberà tutte queste cose cosa
da dove iniziare
non ho capito cosa
c'è scritto che dobbiamo giocare per un
po wow che uk è bello
wow massimo palline sono rimasta
incastrata mi piace nuovo taglio di
capelli o le codine ma dovrebbero caduta
volo qui vicino che aiuta gli emittenti
dalle sigle vv abbiamo ancora sono
quotati secondo per giocare nota meta
ghiaccio ancora aiutami sono rimasto
bloccato dietro di te le guarda che
stiamo preparando la strada per la festa
la persona che ha organizzato tutto non
è ancora arrivata ok il pagliaccio non è
ancora arrivato starà facendo le altre
ragazze dice e in aspetta ma chi ci ha
invitato commercio evitato il pagliaccio
convinto non diceva da parte di chi era
non ti preoccupare
rimani e divertiti
la stanza della festa è pronta dobbiamo
salire anche qui sulle scale focale si
dice di sé dobbiamo trovarci lottare
quali però il paglia 3d segna una
trappola vuol entra con l'arrivo dentro
vuole farci qualcosa mi avete visto la
scorsa il film con il pagliaccio se non
l'avete vista dove vederla come questa
perché fantastica eccoci
finalmente ha detto ora divertitevi un
pochettino e poi il vero divertimento
arriverà e io ho detto ma sbagliò sembra
un po inquietante e vitale dice che
cos'era possiamo non qualcuno ha chiuso
la porta a chiave
fammi vedere si fa chiudere diciamo che
sta succedendo però almeno portate c'è
il cibo
portateci il cibo però mai sabato
impedendoci così hanno fatto la sua
ragione si è trasformata e che cos'è
quello sangue
no no ballava migliorava che stanno
succedendo si può andare wow beh io vado
strano che vita non ha mangiato questi
tramezzini con lui il pagliaccio guardo
ha detto no benvenuti nella mia sala
giochi nel caso che non lo avete capito
ancora dono paci e tu sei io ero mio
prigioniera la sapevo io che c'era
qualcosa che non andava in mater bi è
compatta allora io dico veloci dobbiamo
andare via da qui è
infatti
vai di truman o raddoppia
se questo rumor e il vulcano tipo la
lava
quanti siamo in queste peep lungo gli
altri sono riusciti gli altri forse
senza una pianta e ora siamo in tre a
noi siamo in tre perché gli altri non ci
sono messi al versione ero io mi ha
superato la prima parte auto dobbiamo
andare a qua dentro o dvd spazi piccoli
ad enti affittare preferisce stare qua e
bruciarti nozze lei non ho che andiamo
ma non riesco andare avanti o no
tutti insieme ma che sono io mi perdo
qui è qua non c'è qua non c'è via
d'uscita ok allora dritti dico altro
perché il rum se non lunghissimo un po
inquietanti vada bene forse acquisti no
no
mi conosce quasi preghiamo solo i valori
del pagliaccio che per farmi qualcosa
c'è qualcosa qua sopra
stiamo seguendo
buonissima
portare andiamo possiamo fare una cosa
sembra una sorta di magazzino
c'è una via d'uscita di latte che sta
cucinando qua spero non faceva angolo
attiva che sta cucina abbiamo la pensa
che sia un bollitore di quattro mesi e
quella via d'uscita
dobbiamo orte bloccata forse dobbiamo
premere il pulsante per no
facciamo adesso dobbiamo trovare una
chiave qualcosa proviamo a vedere che
cosa c'è qui intorno e faccio un
biglietto con scritto 3 a 3 perfetto
allora sarà il codice di questa porta
qui prese inserisci il codice in onice
trovo per numeri o che questo in pre
face scritto inviate dell'aiuto e
qualcuno è rimasto incastrato il prof ok
pace
codice da inserire poi c'è un 434 web
vediamo trovare un altro nostro numero
trovato qualcosa no
priviamoci prima che arrivi il
pagliaccio forse qui qui veicolo è un 88
quindi
348 oppure 843 no 834 ok proviamoli
tutti allora io dico 8344 periodo no ora
sbagliato mai provato ad esso
brava petrolio martello vai ok ora
possiamo scappare tappa
pagliaccio dove pensate di andare ma
pensavo che vi state divertendo
non stiamo divertendo insieme stiamo
andando a
fare mi spiace ma non puoi andartene
esplosa di scontro
durato io dentro una gabbia sembra che
siamo dentro lanciamo il circo beh
ovviamente perché un pagliaccio stiamo
in una gabbia gigantesca e 16 fantastico
commento finale dobbiamo trovare una via
d'uscita
beh questa gabbia sembra vecchia e
arrugginita sono sicura che possiamo
romperla se lavoriamo tutti assieme
secondo
proprio parola per dare santario
prostata
ora è meglio che scappiamo ora che
facciamo di tenere meglio scappare
sembra che stia iniziando lo show
dove ha messo pure onde capannone
benvenuti al circo di paci ma che cosa
l'inquietante questo primo atto dobbiamo
evita i cannoni benissimo
hanno preso ragazza non poverino attento
a non farti prendere il nonno poverina
venuto da disintegrata ma
attento
[Musica]
carta restiamo saltando così come gioca
in bur ecco in oman air è detto non c'è
più ha quindi se ti prenderai verso
evento e penso di sì bene ancora più
difficile
a un sembra che abbia finito la palla di
cannone sbagliato meno male non importa
prova a evitare questo invece
no no no
rieccoci qua allora in questo gioco la
cosa brutta è che se perdi se umori
bisogna ricominciare tutto
il sapere che quattro moto mi sono
sfracellato io già
infatti abbiamo dovuto rifare tutto che
possiamo di nuovo qua ora dobbiamo tre
super attenti questo
è
tornato il bagnato con il cannone
dobbiamo stare più attenti questa volta
patetico per molto
ok ok ad oggi non fermo fermo non so
cosa dobbiamo fare adesso aspetta
aspetta di ok
bisogna evitare le porte rotte
tutto fermo
ti sta arrabbiando
se provi massicci aiuti sta arrabbiando
lo sento più
attenta sta diventando sempre più
difficile
sì o no fai rovinando tutto dice
rovinando cosa cosa stai cercando di
fare ucciderci
credo di sì no ti sei sbagliato sistos
visto solo testando vero il clown più
divertente di rho blocks fino a quando
non sono stato vicino e saputo da circo
e le persone si sono dimenticati di me
ora ho bisogno di trovare nuovi
performer e degli show così che farò
sapere che pensi è tornato che comunque
sta parlando
non ne ho idea dico io ma non possiamo
lasciarlo andare ora dobbiamo eseguire
dove sto mandato di quanti qualche mamma
sopravviva ho pensato oh no non riesco a
portare parte di
quanti fatto banca quindi lui vietato
perché è stato dimenticato
esatto è stato prima licenziato e poi
attendiamo ma dove dopo ok siamo molto
attenti giusto che sia molto arrabbiato
che
è così buio un po dentro
lo stavo lo so ancora che si è abbattuta
questa forte che cos'è questo queste
cose che fruttano polvere porta è meglio
andare i servizi non fermarti alle porte
potrebbero essere delle trappole va bene
molto avventurosa questo stile o male
hai visto che cosa io non l'ho detto io
non l'ho visto
non prendermi in giro non è divertente
guardando l'ultimo porta deve essere
questa ci ha scritto farci sopra
questo è il suo camerino è finita paci
dove sei e mi infonde grande deve essere
qua
guarda c'è un passaporto deve esserci
qualcosa di importante qua dentro
dobbiamo trovare una chiave in 5 secondi
no
massimo
dobbiamo nasconderci francesco
laporta si chiude
vivo sopra ma sopra tutto ciò solo io ma
vieni qua siamo nascosti
che la porta è chiusa il rapporto forte
penso che lui sia della storia una
stanza me siamo nascosti ha detto sono
senza aveva sentito una voce siete
riuscito e comunque voi siate stai fermo
immobile ma prima facciamo ora non ce ne
sono forte quello ne è uscita una porta
qui non ho appena sbattuto la testa su
qualcosa la sapevo proprio ho appena
scoperto un tunnel segreto la chiamata
che cosa e adesso fine mio guardaroba
6 parte una porta
che dove abbiamo adesso per fortuna
abbiamo trovato questo tunnel ho trovato
dio
sono contento che siamo riusciti a
scappare da prima ma non siamo al cuore
sicuro sembra che ci siano dei sensori
di movimento sul muro ma ci sia aperto
la porta e ora che dobbiamo fare
sembrare a stanza del manager e
l'ufficio dietro alla reception quello
dove siamo entrati ci sarà quindi a 7
del rumore qualcosa sta andando a fuoco
un decennio come saluto fumo e la
polizia state dovevo andare in suo aiuto
potrebbe essere la nostra ultima chance
di uscita sbrighiamoci ok anche io come
fa che società ci fate tutti ecco chi ha
deciso di unirsi non ascoltatelo uscite
di qualche
incertezza e altre proprio che siamo
così tutto quello che volevo e remo che
per forma e quelli mia circo ok non
farmi del mare nel male non lasciato
andare
no non mi lascio andare altrimenti vi
perderete mi può fidarsi molto
apprezzato lui ci farà saltare in aria
se vai adesso devi andare in tempo cosa
dobbiamo fare stampa non uscire londra
dobbiamo fare
cosa facciamo la salviamo salviamo la
gente abbiamo la ok periodo che non si
faccia saltare in aria vediamo
non ce ne andiamo tenta di te stai
provando essere un eroe del pagliaccio
in mensa va concesso però non è non
vincono mi dispiace
no
io e falsi dobbiamo andarci in ora come
non ci piace e brugnato anche lei voleva
fin troppo l'arci o no adesso oppure a
gestire stavano lavorando assieme tutto
coronato da poco
bat ending problema perché bene dovevamo
salvarci non si caro il mio modo esiste
di salvare lei
questo paragone che amici non abbiamo
avuto un finale sbagliato a
votare
no e questo pagliaccio cattivo noi state
bellissimo così scritto con questa
storia è stata superata vincesse ma una
terra e un film lasciate un bel mi piace
se volete vederne altri ne faremo altre
e ora vi lasciamo fa 4 caselline
significare per vedere inoltre altri
video cliccate su quella che preferite
buona visione ciao